hast du eigentlich schon mal von
postauktionen gehört regelmäßig werden
nämlich z.B von Auktionshaus Weidler
Pakete von Hermes Deutsche Post und so
weiter und so fort online versteigert
dafür habe ich mal 1000 € investiert und
mir ein paar Pakete zukommen lassen
gefunden habe ich unter anderem jede
Menge Damen Bikinis da waren echt ein
paar flotte Modelle bei ein Motorradhelm
mit Freisprechanlage jede Menge
Wandhalterung in ganz vielen
verschiedenen Formen und ganz viel Zeug
was ich jetzt nicht so wirklich zuordnen
konnte und ein Saugroboter war auch noch
dabei irgendwie habe ich zurzeit auch
mit Saugrobotern wenn man alles
zusammenrechnet muss ich sagen für mich
hat sich das jetzt so wirklich gelohnt